alright folks before Tina is gonna talk
I'm gonna share with you something that
I've never said to anyone before in 55
years I figured it out on my own by
thinking so when you put in the flaps
the airplanes nose has to go down so you
put in the flaps nose goes down
think about the tail plane remember the
the tail plane is actually flying in the
downward direction so the angle of
attack of the tail is negative and if
you put the airplane a little bit more
nose down
that increases the angle of attack on
the horizontal stabilizer and it can
become a stalling angle of attack if
that horizontal stabilizer has been
rendered inefficient by Frost does that
make sense so remember the angle of
attack of the wing is positive between
the relative Linda and the wing but the
tail plane is flying down generating
lifts in a downward direction
wings pull up tail pushes down in the
conventional airplane and when you go
little bit more nose down then you have
a higher angle of attack on the tail if
that becomes a strolling angle of attack
it's not generating the necessary
downforce anymore so like the airplane
stalls that makes sense
Francis says yes she's awake all right
well anyway thank you guys for being
here for that unusual moment in my
personal journey
all right today now we're gonna jump
into radar and communications flight
information and we're gonna do a little
thing that you probably haven't done for
a long time especially not here at MIT
we're gonna we're gonna sing the
alphabet together so it's going to be a
great session so we'll start with radar
and air traffic control or ATC services
so what's a transponder why do we have
transponders what does it have to do
with anything
so a transponder is something that helps
enhance your radar return so that the
air-traffic controller can better
understand where your airplane is so who
knows just generally what a radar is
let's step back do people know what
radar is who's um who's seen the the
movie or read the book Hunt for Red
October
goodness only half the class that's
really a shame there's a in that
situation we're talking about sonar but
sonar since it's audible is much easier
sometimes to think about well in that
movie we have some the characters that
are in a submarine and they're trying to
find another submarine so they send out
a sound sonar that goes out and it's
supposed to bounce off of whatever's out
there and come back so if there's a
submarine it'll bounce off so you hear
you know ping and then if it comes back
they can hear the sound coming back well
radar works the same way but it's in the
above the water and we use radar to
detect you know aircraft so the air
traffic control center has a radar that
basically sends out signals that bounce
off of airplanes and come back we also
can use radar for other things like
terrain avoidance of very complex
airplanes not usually your your little
Cessnas but some more complex airplanes
might have a terrain avoidance air radar
system so as they're flying along they
send out a signal it bounces off a
mountain and come
back and it tells you there's a mountain
over there well we want to make sure
that that returns so the signal bouncing
off is very clear and provides as much
information as possible so that the air
traffic controller knows you know where
you are and what aircraft you are so
inside yes really good point so just
just remembering where we are here at
MIT and that radar was invented here at
MIT Wow that's great so a little history
about what was here before the Stata
Center was built here that's really
great thanks so with that great history
about where we are and radar a
transponder is that is actually a piece
of equipment that you have in your
aircraft and this is generally what it
looks like so it has some numbers across
the bottom where you can type in a
particular transponder code or a squawk
code as it's called and there are
different types when we were talking
about the charts and airspace we
discussed how near the class Bravo
we had a big ring around the side that
said mode C transponder so it required a
specific type of transponder so that the
air traffic controllers know exactly
what the altitude is of your aircraft
there are a bunch of different
squawk codes one that it's probably the
most important for you to remember is 1
2 0 0 so that is this the VFR visual
flight squawk code so if you don't have
a particular flight plan going on you'll
need this squawk code dialed in almost
all the time and this is usually a
question on the FAA exam you know if
you're a VFR flight and then they add a
bunch of other things to the question
but if you
VFR flight and you're don't have a
specific flight plan or flight tracking
happening then you should be on that
1,200 squawk code they're also a couple
other ones hopefully you won't have to
deal with this in a small you know two
seater four seater airplane but in case
you get hijacked you need to enter a
particular squawk code seven five zero
zero please don't enter this you know
seriously please don't enter this unless
you mean it you might find yourself
entering this you might hear someone not
actually say the word hijack maybe they
don't want your person hijacking you to
know that that's happening and they
might just say confirm transponders
squawk code seven five zero zero and if
you confirm that means you know you've
been hijacked you might see a special
plane come fly up next to you or
something bad happens so please only use
this if necessary lost comms is really
important seven six zero zero so if you
indicate that so it might be the case
that your transponder is working even if
the your radios for example are not
working so by indicating this that would
be how you tell the air traffic
controller or the for example the tower
controller at your airport that hey I
don't have radio comms and that's when
they would use that lightgun signal to
as we discuss the different colors to
indicate different instructions to you
and then in general if there's just an
emergency if you've lost your engine if
you're declaring an emergency seven
seven zero zero is a great one to just
indicate to everyone that you're in
trouble
so don't accidentally dial in these
squawk codes please be very mindful of
these in particular and in general
there's also an FAA question that comes
up that says you know what's a squawk
code you don't want to dial in
accidentally and those are those three
at the bottom okay so let's just take a
step back and talk about this in general
when I first became a pilot before I was
you know learned all this material I was
under the impression that you pretty
much always had to have a flight plan
that before you flew anywhere you had to
decide you know where you were going
to file a flight plan yet to communicate
to different people and tell them that
this is where you were gonna go and get
it approved and then when you took off
you had to fly exactly that flight plan
well it turns out that's not that's not
always the case and in fact that's only
usually the case on specific types of
flights or an instrument flight for
example but most of the time in general
aviation on a good weather day you don't
have to file a flight plan and most of
the time most people don't file a flight
plan you can even decide what you're
doing after you've taken off it's a good
idea to know in advance generally where
you're flying because you need to know
certain those required things we talked
about you know airports in the vicinity
fuel runway length but if you always fly
kind of in your home Airport area so if
you fly here at Lawrence or you fly it
out of Bedford Beverly one of the local
airports and you're familiar with all
the airports in the area when you take
off on a given day you don't necessarily
have to tell anyone in advance where
you're going you might go with an
instructor and that instructor kind of
as you're flying will decide you know we
should do a couple landings at Worcester
we should practice an instrument
approach at Lawrence or whatever they're
deciding in the air and so you don't
have to file these flight plans so when
you're in the air there are certain
times that you don't actually have to
talk to anyone and we discuss the
different classes of airspace if as long
as you're not in a class of airspace
where you have to be specifically
communicating you can actually just take
off without a lot of communication
equipment and just look outside the
airplane to avoid aircraft and go where
you're going but if you do want to have
some some guidance let's so let's say
you're flying somewhere you're not in a
class Bravo or a class to Charlie
airspace but you know say you're just
taking a taking a flight you want to go
south to Provincetown let's say and
while you're flying you just want to
have an additional pair of eyes in the
sky to help you know if there's a really
bad quick changing weather front coming
in that may be developed that you didn't
notice before you took off which usually
we'll talk about weather data hopefully
you'll know in advance or you just want
to be aware and alerted to other traffic
in the area traffic meaning other air
flying in the area so you can actually
choose is a voluntary thing to call in
and ask the air traffic controllers to
give you those traffic advisories and
there are different types of services
available in different areas there are
even parts of the country where it's not
available at all so even if you wanted
to have someone to talk to when you're
flying up there to tell you what's going
on there is no radar service in all
parts of the country so how do you
request the the service so you can do it
a couple ways depending on where you are
sometimes when you're still on the
ground before you've taken off you're
taxing or you're in the run-up area you
can ask for certain types of flight
services but a lot of times it's after
you've taken off from the airport after
you're have left the tower controller
and you've switched to a local radar and
you want to ask for some some types of
radar following so in general whenever
you do a radio call you start with who
you're talking to so in this case Boston
approached the Boston approach is who
you're talking to and then who you are
so in this example Cirrus 7:07 whiskey
tango so that's the name of the airplane
that you're in and the tail number and
then you have to say where you are so
they can try to find you so you can say
five south of Hanscom so that means
you're five miles south of Hanscom or
bedford field and then what you want why
you're calling
so requesting VFR advisories
Provincetown so that's saying kind of
where you're going and what you're
asking for help with so once you do that
the and first of all before you call in
you want to listen to the radio for just
a moment to make sure you don't talk
over somebody but once you make that
call you're waiting for the approach
controller to call you back and so if
they call you back they'll they'll say
who they're talking to first so that's
you so 7 whiskey Tango and then they'll
tell you what to do squawk 4-2-3-1 so
that means to type into your transponder
the numbers 4-2-3-1 and ident so
identies short for identify and there's
an ident button on your transponder when
you hit
I dent it basically blinks on their
screen to make them find you easier with
all the all the airplanes on their
screen okay and it's also possible that
you call the the controller and you
don't hear any response maybe they're
busy doing some other things so you give
them a little bit of time you can just
make your call again and hope that they
respond to you and once the controller
tells you you know radar contact so
that's where they you know they say that
they found you on their screen so you
know radar contact seven miles south of
the Bedford Airport
that means they they caught you and in
this example as you can see it took it
took you you travel two miles before
they actually got the radar contact
sometimes that happens when you're
getting traffic advisories they do it in
reference to a clock so if you remember
you guys have to go back and remember
your analog clocks and you know just so
I do it to you guys so you're looking
here so you know one o'clock two o'clock
three o'clock you know so basically it's
like a clock and they're trying to do it
in reference to you so when you're you
flying the plane look at your three
o'clock it means look out your right
window it just noted that wind can
affect that sometime so so even if they
said three o'clock it might be at two
o'clock so just keep that in mind so
we'll just do a little practice question
here so here just to make it easy we're
saying the polite pilot is flying on a
heading of three six zero so why is that
easy
well three six zero is north and so
North sometimes makes it easy to think
about so if you're flying on a heading
of three six zero degrees and the
controller says traffic 10 o'clock two
miles
southbound where are you looking for
this traffic so a B or C shout it out
a-alright good so you're you're flying
north and so when you're talking about
traffic at 10 o'clock so 10 o'clock will
be a little bit to your left so that's
the 10 o'clock and then two miles is
kind of how far away that is and the
direction that traffic is going yes it's
completely so the question was is the
clock relative to you so it is relative
to you so we just made it easy by saying
you're flying three six zero or North
but yes if you were flying South one
eight zero it's still gonna be if they
say 10 o'clock it's still going to be
out your left window a little bit
forward but in that direction it's going
to be now South East good question okay
so we we've already talked about this a
little bit yesterday the ADIS or
automatic terminal information service
so we talked about that when we're
looking at the charts and we talked
about the ADIS frequency so it's a
frequency you can dial in and basically
it's information that's being broadcast
so when you dial into that particular
frequency you get a certain amount of
information now the first couple times I
admit when you hear this 8's information
it seems very overwhelming and you might
have to listen to it three times four
times even understand what they're
saying but I trust you it gets a lot
easier over time so they give you a
whole bunch of information so they give
you the airport name that's really
important to listen to maybe you dialed
the frequency and wrong and you're
getting the ATIS information from a
completely wrong airport so look at the
airport location and then the letter so
they they'll say you know bedford
information whiskey so that letter is
just the referring to the most recent
update so that way if you let's say you
listen to it it says information whiskey
then you go off you do some practice
turns and whatever and you're coming
back to Bedford and you dial it in if
it's still information whiskey then you
don't have to listen to the whole
recording you already have that
information but if it's
now advanced to the next letter than you
know it's new information so you need to
listen to it so a whole bunch of weather
information is provided here so it will
give you the time will explain what we
mean by Zulu time the wind visibility
ceiling those types of informations it
also tell you local information so if a
certain taxiway is closed or right now
you're likely to get a lot of those
warnings because there's snow everywhere
so they might have piled up snow on
certain parts of the airport
so they'll indicate that those different
taxiways or runways might be closed so
in case you want to listen and practice
to listening to different ADA TSA's this
is an example you can you can click on
and listen to what it is there's also a
phone number that I've highlighted here
so you can just use your regular phone
call that number and you can listen to
the ATIS information and it updates
approximately once an hour it can it can
update more often especially if weather
is changing frequently there are also
flight service stations and you can
there's a lot of way to get weather data
so when you're on the ground before your
flight and you're preparing you can
actually get a weather briefing you can
get a full weather briefing it's very
important to do this especially before
your FAA check ride but but also any
kind of cross-country flights it's a
good idea to call in and you can provide
your tail number you can indicate you
know where where you're starting Airport
is where your destination Airport is
when you plan to take off how long you
plan to be in flight and then that way
they know what weather data to give you
and they'll actually just tell you all
the information that you need to know in
a very long spiel so you want to be
ready to write all that information down
but what's really great about that also
is that you know they have a they also
keep a record that you called in and
that you got this weather data and so
it's one way to kind of demonstrate that
you've adequately prepared for the
flight and gotten the appropriate
weather briefing in advance
all right so radio procedures so this is
where we're gonna do our fun alphabet
test here so
actually did this last year but some
people said they kind of forgot the
alphabet so it wasn't that they forgot
that you know B stood for Bravo they
just forgot what letter of the alphabet
came next so to remove that as an excuse
for you I have the full alphabet here
and together we're gonna see how much
you know about the full Aviation
phonetic alphabet so what they mean is
instead of saying a you say alpha
instead of saying B say Bravo
so let's let's go through together so
let's start from the top
alpha Bravo Charlie Delta echo Foxtrot
Golf Hotel India Juliet kilo Lima Mike
November Oscar papa Quebec Romeo Sierra
tango uniform Victor whiskey Yankee Zulu
all right
good job so I I know that some of you
aren't familiar with that and that's
totally fine so if you were just
listening along that's okay it's good to
just get used to hearing it but it's a
good thing to practice and you might
notice that in your in your daily life
you have to especially if you're someone
like me that has a very long last name
Shrivastav I have to spell it out to
people I love to use my aviation
phonetic alphabet to do that and you
might find a fellow pilot on the other
end of the line so that's always fun to
do but it's good to just start
practicing this and get used to it not
only is it a fun trick you can whip out
when you need to but it's extremely
helpful just to have that kind of
memorized and be familiar with that
there in terms of the numbers you pretty
much just say the numbers sometimes
people say Niner instead of nine some
people don't also instead of saying
three they say tree a lot of people
consider that pretentious and they don't
like it wouldn't you do that but
officially you're supposed to say tree
instead of three it's supposedly easier
to hear on the radios there's also
different ways that you
describe a number so in if you're
talking about 1200 feet like your
altitude you say 1200 but if you're over
10,000 then you say 1-0 thousand and
then if you're talking about a frequency
where you have a decimal point so you
would say one to four point four so it's
really important to do that because if
you start saying 124 point four then you
take up too much time on the radio and
people aren't used to hearing the
numbers that way it can confuse people
so just a question to make sure you've
gotten that so a B or C right so 1-0
thousand five hundred there's inevitably
a question on the FAA exam about this
it's not that hard to do but please
please try to remember it all right so
Zulu time is the same as the UTC time so
does anyone know what time zone we're
currently in Eastern but is it Eastern
Standard Time or Eastern Daylight Time
Eastern Standard Time that's right and
you know how many hours that is
different from the Zulu time five right
so you subtract five from the Zulu time
to get our Eastern Standard Time and
does it stay like that year-round no so
when when it turns into Daylight Time in
the March time frame then do you do
minus 6 or minus 4 minus 4 so it's good
to just know that because a lot of the
weather data and information is provided
in Zulu time and you might need to
convert it to your local time zone so
when you're speaking on the radio it's
very important to know that you know
that radio is for essential purposes
it's primarily you know it needs to be
available if somebody's having emergency
if somebody's lost or disoriented if
somebody's having a problem so you don't
just speak and talk on the radio unless
you have something in particular to say
that logic goes out the door if you're
at a very tiny
not very often used airport the other
thing to keep in mind is that a lot of
the the communication radios operate at
VHF or very high frequency which means
that it's line-of-sight so if there's a
mountain range in between you and what's
transmitting then you won't be able to
hear that connection so there are a
number of airports in the Northeast that
are kind of nestled in between some
mountains you got to be very careful in
mountains Philip talked a lot about fog
associated with mountains and different
wind effects in your mountains so
mountains are not something to be
trifled with but in addition you may not
have proper radio communications so if
you're trying to land at an airport in
the mountains you may not be able to get
the ATIS unless you fly high enough that
you have a line of sight to that Airport
above the mountains for example and then
whenever you're using the radio we
already briefly cover this with one
example but it's good you know there are
a couple things you need to say so you
need to say you so Who am I talking to
first and then who I am where I am what
I want and then sometimes you have to
say with with meaning like what
information you have with you so they
and that's referring to the ADIS so if
you are trying to take off from Hanscom
Airport and you have received the ATIS
information whiskey then you say with
whiskey because if you don't say whiskey
then they they might not know if you
have the right barometric pressure
setting for example or you might not
know that an airport runway is closed so
they want to make sure you have the
right information so this is an example
so first whenever you get on the radio
don't just start talking first listen to
make sure you're not talking over
anybody and then state all those in that
type of information so this is the in
this particular example it's a Cessna
coming back to Hanscom to land there so
you would say you know you're talking to
Hanscom towers you would say Hanscom
tower skyhawk november five three five
six Niner five miles west of the field
field is referring to the airport
inbound for landing so that's what I
want with information with
and one thing to keep in mind with all
radio communications you are the pilot
in command it's important that you first
aviate which is fly the plane
then navigate make sure you know where
you're going and last communicate it's
really important because sometimes there
can be a very aggressive air traffic
controller on the phone trying to get
you to respond or even if you've
declared an emergency trying to trying
to help you and if you need to tell them
to stand by if you even need to unplug
your communications so if you can focus
on landing the plane you should do that
because a v8 is most important then
navigate and finally communicate and if
the air traffic controller gives you any
instruction regardless of how how
assertively they tell you to do
something you can just say unable that
means you're not going to do it they
have to figure out a way around it they
have to either move other planes out of
the way and you're telling them what
you're doing so in the unfortunate case
of the ultimately positive case of
captain Sully landing in the Hudson if
you hear you know watch the movie if you
hear the recordings of that you hear
that the air traffic controller is
trying to be really helpful and it's
trying to say you know hey you can land
at Teterboro
you know I've cleared all these airports
for you and in Captain Sully just says
unable so there's a common traffic
advisory frequency or C Taff so this is
where there are a lot of airports
increasingly unfortunately due to budget
cuts or more and more airports that
don't have operating control towers so
in these spaces you you have a frequency
that airplanes can just talk to each
other on to make sure you know they're
coordinating with other people there so
I'm gonna give you a couple examples and
procedures so you want to do your first
call ten miles away from the airport and
then just report certain things so when
you're entering as the downwind base the
final these are the legs of the traffic
pattern to land when you're leaving
also when you're taxing on the field
those are the things that you would want
to call out on the radio and nobody will
respond to you sometimes you just say
that so that anyone who's around who
might be in the vicinity can hear that
there's another
playing and what you're doing and so
just kind of tying it back to when we
were looking at the charts so here's a
snapshot from a sectional chart so you
see in the middle there there's a tiny
little airport says that Jamestown so if
you want to figure out what the sea Taff
is so just zooming in there so you can
see where it says in magenta Jamestown
it talks about the airport it first
gives the a sauce which is that
automated weather information it gives
you more information there that it's the
bottom right numbers one two three point
zero is that sea Taff
so that's the frequency at which you
would just announce that you're coming
in that you're landing etc so there are
a lot of different radar facilities you
may not necessarily interact with all of
these as a private pilot but there are
things called clearance delivery they
they're really frequently at busy
airports and they talk about you know a
lot of specific operations you probably
won't deal with this much as a private
pilot just getting your first license
ground control you'll definitely talk to
if you're at Hanscom even at Lawrence
there's usually both a tower and ground
and so you once you're when you're when
you're ready to enter the runway so
you've finished your engine run-up
you're lined up waiting to enter the
runway that's when you talk to tower you
tell them that you want to take off and
then they give you clearance to take off
and when you're flying and approaching
the airport you're talking the tower but
once you've landed and you exit the
active runway then you switch over to
ground and ground will tell you how to
taxi around the runway and get to
wherever you're parking your airplane so
if you lose your communications the
first thing you should do is actually
make sure you did lose your
communications turns out vast majority
of the time you actually just bumps your
plug out of the socket and you just need
to plug it in or you turned your volume
down or you're not talking on the right
frequency so make sure all of that's
working because it doesn't it's very
infrequent that your comms actually
we die but if they do we've talked about
how you can enter that transponder code
and an indicate that you don't have your
comms available so we and we talked
about that that transponder code is
seven six zero zero so that's the last
lost communications and depending on the
class of airspace they might give you a
light gun signals to tell you what to do
or you could actually just go to an
unpowered Airport where you don't
require communications with anyone and
you can and just kind of look around see
and avoid other aircraft and land you
can also transmit in case it's the fact
that your ability to hear has died but
your ability to transmit is still live
so you can still transmit you know I'm
approaching such-and-such Airport I'm
entering the final but don't
continuously transmit because keep in
mind it might be that your transmission
is working just great you just can't
hear so don't clog up the entire radio
this is just a review of those lightgun
signals as well okay so emergency
procedures there are a lot of different
emergency procedures but here we're
focusing on from a radios and comms
perspective again you need to first a v8
then navigate then communicate so so the
first things you do it really depends on
what the emergency is right if it's an
engine failure then your focus is on
pitching to an appropriate airspeed so
that you can get the the greatest time
and distance to where you need to land
finding a place to land and trying to
restart your engine that aside with with
regard to the radios and the
communications there is an emergency
frequency one 21.5 there's a squawk code
seven seven zero zero we already talked
about that and you can radio just Mayday
Mayday Mayday that alerts folks of the
fact that you have an emergency we also
discussed when we were talking about
required equipment on your aircraft
there's a such thing called an ELT or
emergency locator transmitter and this
thing basically turns on by itself
and we'll basically broadcast where you
are and it needs to be tested fairly
often you can actually tune into the
frequency that it's emitting at to test
if it is transmitting okay
flight information this is our last big
section so this is talking about
information around an airport so I'm
going to grab the for flight again so
again just like with the case of the
sectional there's always a physical
version or an electronic version so the
picture you see on the slide is the it's
something that you could actually look
at so there's an airport flight
directory so that that will give you the
types of information you're looking at
or on a on a for flight and I'll pass
this around you can search a particular
airport and get the same information so
I'll just pass this around so there's a
lot of good information we already
discussed some of it when we were first
talking about charts and and runway
markings and runway lengths and those
types of things but from a
communications perspective it also has a
lot of great information with regard to
what the ATIS is what the tower
frequency is with the ground all of that
type of information and we've also
discussed previously the far aim very
large book of regulations there are a
number of other types of notices called
notices to Airmen or NOTAMs and NOTAMs
basically can can be warnings of
different types of things we've we've
discussed TFRs or temporary flight
restrictions but you might also get a no
Tim that you know there's parachute
jumping in the area so you know watch
out for that happening sometimes there's
also an advisory circular these are not
not required or binding but information
that is put out to help you understand
or clarify if there's confusion with
regulations so okay I have the answer up
here for for you but just a couple
practice questions so this one is about
basic radar service and so this is
talking about what we were just
describing and if you call up and ask
for for flight following what are they
providing you well they're providing a
safety alerts traffic advisories
sometimes they'll do vectoring so what
do I mean by vectoring is you know let's
say there's traffic traffic 12 o'clock 3
miles that means there's traffic right
in front of you 3 miles away and then
they come back and you and you know
you're saying you know looking for
traffic you can't find the traffic they
say traffic 12 o'clock
two miles you know in the same altitude
it's you so if you're at 3,000 they say
3,000 and then you still can't see it
and you're just like you know negative
traffic so then they'll they'll just
tell you you know heading through you
know they'll just give you another
heading so they'll give you a number so
heading 3 6 0 or they'll say turn 10
degrees left and so that is what they
mean by limited vectoring so they'll
tell you what to do for a little bit to
avoid something dangerous
you